[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 les invités on passe
immédiatement au titre parole à marie
laure rousseau conseillère municipale à
la mairie de saint cyr en charge de la
culture
nous ferons un point avec elle sur la
saison 2017-2018 et puis nous recevons
aussi sur le plateau abdel dessoubre le
nouveau président du club de foot de
trappes
nous verrons avec lui ses objectifs pour
la saison à venir
mais ce week end s'est tenue la sixième
édition du forum logement organisé par
l'université de versailles saint quentin
c'est l'occasion pour les étudiants de
découvrir les logements sur le site pour
la rentrée prochaine
plusieurs acteurs sur le territoire ont
pu proposer leur offre aux visiteurs
nicolas demandé à rencontrer pascal mani
glee le responsable service logement a
lu vs q ce forum logement permet aux
étudiants qui sont la recherche d'un
logement de présenter l'offre de
logement qui est présente sur tout le
territoire
51 en effet quelles sont les
caractéristiques de l'offre de logements
sur saint quentin en yvelines
donc quel est-il ce forum nous pouvons
présenter aux étudiants différents types
de logements donc vers les logements en
résidence avec la présence des
différents partenaires qui sont les plus
gros bailleurs sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines
peut-être que le service habitat de la
communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines ont mis le crous de
l'académie de versailles
le claj de 50 ans ghislain sic de
versailles aussi arpège alors est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer les
caractéristiques de ces différents
acteurs donc avec les résidences que je
vais présenter sont les plus gros
bailleur en termes de logement au niveau
des résidences
nous avons aussi des logements des
offres de particuliers
donc les étudiants peu
à la rigueur en fer venant au forum
rencontrer les particuliers qui sont
présents sur place et ainsi avoir accès
à toutes les offres de logements sont
présentés par le particulier qui sont
inscrits sur nos plateformes logement de
l'université non la troisième solution
c'est le logement intergénérationnel
nous avons comme partenaire qui est
présent aussi l'association
ensemble2générations quels sont les
critères des étudiants pour choisir leur
logement oui c'est bien sûr le lieu
géographique et bien sûr le montant du
loyer et ensuite on va voir ce que les
autres services qui peuvent avoir au
niveau des réservations est il une
réelle différence entre l'offre privée
et l'offre publique de logement étudiant
non depuis quelques années
en termes de coûts le montant des loyers
s'est considérablement réduite
généralement les offres de logement
présentée par le par le puits par le
crous et ainsi que par les votes pour
résidence privée il n'y a pas beaucoup
de différence ensuite le choix des
étudiants va se jouer sur certains
services qui sont proposés par certaines
résidences sorte
quel genre de service par certaines
résidences vos yeux sur le fait qu'il ya
des salles de sport une salle
d'animation ou proposer d'autres
services avec des animateurs qui sont
présents au sein des résidences par
exemple au niveau des prix il aussi à
quel niveau à l'heure actuelle
généralement en moyenne pour
un logement résidents faut compter à peu
près 400 en tant que directeur du
logement étudiant à lui vs q quels
conseils vous pouvez donner aux
étudiants qui recherchent un logement
voilà moi ce que je peux donner aux
étudiants qui recherchent un logement ne
pas hésiter à postuler auprès des
différents bailleurs qui sont présents
sur le territoire de la communauté
d'agglomération là rien ne vous empêche
de faire une demande de réservation une
demande de radiation ne vous engage en
rien du tout voilà donc qu'est-ce que ce
que je conseille c'est de postuler
envers tous les organismes qui vous
intéresse et une fois que vous avez une
réponse positive
vous sélectionnez l'organisme qui vous
intéresse si vous annulez les autres
demandent si vous multipliez vos chances
de trouver un jour et non pas se
concentrer uniquement sur une seule
demande et on passe un tout autre sujet
nous recevons marie-laure rousseau
conseillère municipale à la mairie de
saint cyr en charge de la culture pour
faire un point sur la saison 2017-2018
bonsoir alors qu'est ce qui nous attend
dans cette saison 2017-2018
vous allez avoir beaucoup de belles
surprises
nous choisissons à saint cyr d'avoir une
programmation à la fois diversifiée de
qualité à la fois aussi classique et
moderne et qui s'adresse à tous les
publics
donc nous avons en particulier beaucoup
de théâtre pour commencer il ya des
comédies très légère comme par exemple
éveil du chameau et avec aure atika nous
avons aussi une pièce
avec martin lamotte sur colombo le
célèbre détective de la série télévisée
c'est très amusant il la joue très bien
et je veux aller le voir
bien sûr bien sûr parce que c'est un
grand classique tout le monde le connaît
je crois que vraiment c'est pour tous
pour tous les âges et on a aussi une
pièce d'un auteur américain tennessee
williams et s'est jouée par francis
lalanne
c'est vrai qu'il est dans cette
programmation et on le connaissait on
connaît chanteur c'est vrai que il a eu
certes un rôle d'acteur mais là vous me
disiez à au début de l'émission que
c'est particulier on l'attend plus tôt
dans son rôle de chanteur mais il se
révèle un excellent acteur d'ailleurs il
a joué aussi dans d'autres pièces dans
d'autres distributions et hélas il joue
parfaitement un rôle difficile mais qui
joue à la perfection et pour les plus
jeunes
alors vous voulez au bout leur
conseillez quoi alors les plus jeunes ya
beaucoup de choses pour les plus jeunes
il ya en particulier un spectacle de
magie qui leur plaira beaucoup c'est
alain choquette qui vient du québec et
qui nous séduira par tous ses tours de
magie qui sont vraiment très
impressionnant était aussi au festival
du rire ça oui oui oui c'est bien
et quoi d'autre qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent
dès qu'on perd par la magie
à part la magie ils ont aussi beaucoup
de musique s'adresse à eux
bon on a de la musique des années 80 où
ils peuvent venir danser avec leurs
parents leurs amis
il ya aussi d'autres types de musiques
d'europe de l'est et il ya aussi les
spectacles pour les jeunes jeune public
je le précise parce que alors jeune
chaîne publique c'est tout aux 6-12 ans
non et quand j'ai dit jeunes c'est
plutôt 12-18 ben coremans et des 6-12
ans alors qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent aller
boire avec leurs parents et bien le
spectacle d'alain choquette la musique
tout ce que je viens de dire elle est
plus jeune ben quoi on a deux spectacles
pourront qui sont spécialement dédiés ou
très jeune public
dites moi vous voulez préparer un an à
l'avancé pour cette programmation ça se
passe comment ah oui tout à fait il faut
beaucoup anticipé j'ai commencé en
septembre dernier
voilà il faut à peu près 6 8 mois pour
tout préparer tout mettre en oeuvre et
cette année je suis très contente parce
que la plaquette est sorti en juin
et c'est un peu plus tôt que d'habitude
et comme ça ça permettra aux cinq
syriens et tous ceux qui veulent venir
au spectacle de réserver dès maintenant
leur place parce que là la billetterie
est ouverte dès maintenant
quel message vous les transmettre à
travers cette programmation
je voudrais transmettre un message de
culture je voudrais que la culture
d'abord soins accessibles à tous et que
elle apparaît sous toutes ses formes
tout sur toutes ses sensibilités
artistiques scaglia le théâtre la
musique le
les spectacles pour enfants et la magie
voilà et voilà je voudrais que chacun y
trouve son compte et à travers une
expression artistique de qualité donc là
la plaquette elle est faite vous allez
commencer à préparer dès septembre si
j'ai bien compris la suit exactement
c'est tellement une idée déjà oui j'ai
déjà des idées de pièces de théâtre
je tends là je peux pas dévoiler via un
secret quand même je peux pas vous
dévoiler fera sur ce secret mais beau
monde à la plaquette et c'est tout au
long de l'année
voilà et puis la billetterie est déjà
ouverte donc tout le monde peut y aller
alors les prix varient entre sont entre
6 et et 34 euros mais il ya beaucoup de
tarifs abonnement jeune groupe et
j'invite à chacun de se rapprocher de la
billetterie parce que vraiment ils y
trouveront leur compte
et bien je vous remercie on va passer à
un tout autre sujet est ce que vous vous
y connaissez bien en foot
alors là pas du tout eh bien nous allons
en savoir beaucoup plus et surtout sur
le foot dont sur le territoire on reçoit
ce soir abdel guessoum le nouveau
président du club de foot de trappes
bonsoir alors déjà comment vous sentez à
cette place ses premiers pas alors un
bon tout je voudrais rendre un hommage
et un rôle un grand remerciement à
l'ancien président qui est moustapha
larbaoui qui a l'habitude d'être dans
vos plateaux je l'espère vous avec lui
donc voilà je voulais simplement dire
que ça a été très émouvant cette
assemblée générale qui a eu lieu le
samedi 24
parce que avoir un bonhomme comme lui à
la tête de ce club depuis 14 ans il a
fait beaucoup de choses pour ce club
la création de l'académie la création de
la section féminine
toutes les équipes
de l'école de foot jusqu'en seniors au
niveau régional son territoire les
portes pour le moment sur sur la casse
qui on va dire un sirop sky sur les
douze clubs sur les 12 villes on est le
seul club où on est mieux placé au
niveau régional la région
donc voilà il a fait un très grand
travail avec une équipe une grande
équipe d'éducateurs le club c'est 40
éducateurs à peu près ces mille neuf
licenciés pour cette saison avec une
section féminine qui est à peu près aux
alentours de son nez à cent vingt 120
féminines toutes sections confondues de
l'école de foot aux seniors elle en dit
moi lors de cette ag
c'est vous ces meules été élu avec
dignité
digne héritier vous avez bonne idée que
voulait mettre en place ça va être quoi
votre présidence voilà un président
c'est ce qui va être important c'est de
se maintenir
ce que mustapha a mis en place cet
héritage donc il lui laisse un club
comme il l'a expliqué à la survie
générale un club structuré un club
apaisé et un club sera donc maintenant
il ya plus qu'à entretenir tout ça et
voir développer d'autres d'autres
actions à l'avenir donc les drones et
autres actions c'est vraiment on va
accentuer sur la section féminine là
pour nous pour moi ou pas cette fois
pour mustapha larbaoui on est d'accord
là dessus c'est l'avenir c'est l'avenir
dans les années à venir sur
la section féminine rattraper lyon et le
paris-sg quelques années mais je vous
assure c'est un secteur qui va bachand
se développer et qui va apporter
beaucoup pour la coop pour la ville qui
va botter qui va porter pour réussi ce
nouveau coup on va vraiment qui sont
tués sur la section féminine et on a un
super coach qui qu'ils soient n'occupe
qui sera au rodrigues qui sont en occupe
depuis deux ans et qui fait un travail
fabuleux sur la section féminine et qui
va encore s'agrandir et se développer un
peu plus en ce qui concerne les autres
les autres équipes
comment ça va se passer pour celle qui
en régionale donc nous pour les seniors
ont organisé la montée j'imagine
effectivement on n'a pas été très loin
encore cette année mais c'est pour ça
que cette question est arrivé on a on
arrive et si je dis pas qu'à three
quatrième des prairies entre 4ème et
5ème pas très loin pour une montée on
l'a on l'a raté de très peu
voilà mais oui effectivement c'est comme
jeudi dans un club il ya une équipe
phare c'est l'équipe senior celle qui va
drainer qui va apporter du monde et
attire les autres donc effectivement on
va continuer le travail pour avoir une
montée l'année prochaine et j'y crois
avec le coach arnaud un nbc qui est
manager du club et qui en même temps en
charge deux des équipes seniors et qui
fait un travail aussi fabuleux et j'ai
toute confiance en lui et on va faire un
grand travail pour pouvoir maintenant
accéder à une
à une montée supplémentaire en et
prochaine et bien je vous le souhaite en
tout cas
vous irez au club de foot oui tu voulons
qui gérait peut-être voir un spectacle à
sacyr
c'est ce qu'on arrive à faire aux 7,8
invités je vous remercie de nous avoir
subi merci aussi à vous d'être venu sur
le plateau merci amis je vous souhaite à
tous bonne soirée
[Musique]